je voudrais saluer monsieur le premier
ministre et je donne maintenant la
parole notre collègue madame elisabeth
lamure pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole de ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du travail et de
l'emploi
monsieur le ministre une fois encore le
malaise est grand après l'annonce lundi
soir des chiffres du chômage
chacun de nous souffrent de cette
mauvaise nouvelle qui masque un peu les
timides perspectives de croissance
alors une fois encore allons nous
entendre les mêmes arguments dilatoire
pour cacher l'échec du président de la
république qui dès 2013 a conditionné
lui même la réussite de son action à sa
capacité à inverser la courbe du chômage
une fois encore allons nous entendre le
rappel de la situation d'avant 2012
comme seule justification
les chiffres du mois d'avril parmi les
plus mauvais depuis le début du
quinquennat confirme la tendance
rien ne semble ralentir le mouvement
infernale et pire toutes les classes
d'âge sont touchées
et alors qu'en france nous dépassons
allègrement les 10 % de chômeurs nos
voisins allemands et anglais connaissent
des courbe descendante à -2 6% et de
plus il crée en majorité des emplois
dans des secteurs à forte valeur ajoutée
et nous en france nous créons des
emplois aidés vous en annonces et cent
mille de plus cette année un coût de
plus de 3 milliards d'euros par an pour
financer quatre cent cinquante mille
contrats aidés mais c'est dans le
secteur marchand que les emplois
créeront la richesse d'ailleurs que nous
disent les entreprises
depuis six mois la délégation aux
entreprises du sénat a rencontré chez
eux
plus d'une centaine d'entrepreneurs et
tous nous tiennent le même langage moins
de contraintes - de normes moins de
charges et ils nous disent oui nous
voudrions embaucher mais de grâce lever
les freins à l'embauché
or le gouvernement balance entre donner
des gages à la gauche de sa majorité et
accepter les règles de la compétitivité
d'un monde ouvert
mais les français ne vous croient plus
et il ne vous suivent plus alors comment
comptez vous sortir de ce dilemme
monsieur le ministre
j'ajouterai comme l'a rappelé notre
président bruno retailleau ne laissez
pas passer la formidable occasion de
prendre de vraies mesures en faveur de
la croissance
en acceptant tout le travail que la
majorité sénatoriale a fait sur la loi
de votre collègue monsieur macron merci
pour vous répondre
la parole est à françois rebsamen maëlys
du travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice elisabeth lamure
vous vous avez cité des chiffres et j'ai
noté que vous aviez indiqué que le taux
de chômage était largement au-dessus des
10% de chômage dans notre pays
j'ai cru que vous n'aviez pas entendu
les informations qui venait de tomber ce
matin et qui tu es les chiffres que
l'insee venait de publier puisque
l'insee vient d'annoncer que le taux de
chômage avait reculé en france au
premier trimestre et qu'il était vous
avez tort
vous avez tort chers collègues vous avez
tort de vous moquer des chiffres qui
servent de comparaison internationale
parce que ces chiffres sont les seuls
qui sont reconnues au niveau
international et donc c'est c'est une
réalité que vous ne pouvez pas c'est une
réalité que vous ne pouvez pas nier et
que je voulais vous indiquez je pensais
bien évidemment vous alliez comme moi
vous réjouir de cette annonce et je
regrette que vous ne fassiez pas et donc
que faire pour améliorer cette situation
bien faire je le crois ce que nous
faisons pour encourager la reprise
d'activité économique et préparer nos
chômeurs à pouvoir demain par la
formation être prêt à répondre aux
offres d'emplois qui vont être présentés
c'est pourquoi nous avons mis en place
un dispositif d'emploi aidé c'est vrai
dont vous avez vous même largement que
vous avez vous même largement utilisé le
super me de regarder l'histoire des
contrats aidés d'étonnant le pic a été
atteint sous quelqu'un que vous aimez
bien qu'il s'agit de l'ancien premier
ministre alain juppé
soit la jupe et il y avait huit cent
cinquante mille contrats aidés et même
pendant le premier semestre 2012
vous en aviez programmé 385 milles 385
milles d'ailleurs vous avez utilisé les
deux tiers vous en avez utilisé les deux
tiers d'ici le mois de mai 2012 et donc
voilà
et nous mettons en place au contraire
des politiques qui sont des politiques
de soutien à l'activité
et pour ce faire deux lois sont en
discussion en ce moment l'une qui est
porté par mon collègue emmanuel macron
qui portent sur la croissance et
l'activité est une autre que je présente
devant vous qui est celle sur le
dialogue social tout cela un but lever
les freins et redonner la confiance des
entreprises car ce sont elles qui créent
l'emploi
merci monsieur lui nice